[Music]
it has defeated more armies than any
general
laid the foundations for many of today's
racial tensions
it even kick-started the modern
environmental movement
and it's not visible to the naked eye
the malaria parasite and the mosquito
that transmits it have probably affected
human history more than
any other creatures we share the planet
with from migration to wars
politics to poverty malaria continues to
shape the world in surprising and
profound ways
[Music]
malaria has shaped the development of
some of the world's most powerful
institutions
and empires
ancient rome relied on mosquito-infested
marshes
to protect it from invaders who often
succumb to malaria
[Music]
the disease cost hannibal his right eye
his wife
his son and much of his army without
mosquitoes
rome might have fallen in ancient times
malaria was simply called the roman
fever because it was so prevalent in and
around rome
whether it's the carthaginians the huns
the visigoths the vandals the pontine
marshes
it essentially acts as a shield you know
protecting the eternal city
that's one of the reasons why today so
many of us speak languages that are
derived from latin
the roman empire was one of the things
that helped spread christianity
around europe and then ultimately the
world
some humans developed a limited immunity
to the disease
tens of thousands of years ago when the
first of a series of genetic mutations
occurred among
farmers in africa thousands of years
later these mutations
and the resistance they granted were one
reason why the transatlantic slave trade
was so horribly profitable when africans
were shipped to the new world to work on
mosquito-infested sugar and tobacco
plantations
they were much more likely to survive
than indigenous or european indentured
labourers
who quickly died of malaria
this drove up the price of african
slaves and fueled the odious trade in
human beings
which in turn shaped the racial contours
of both north and south america
malaria is one of the main reasons why
today a large proportion
of the population of the americas are
the descendants of people who were
brought there involuntarily
we have to remember america went through
a civil war
essentially partly due to slavery
obviously the repercussion of that
we're still living with today in the
united states
no question today africa carries the
heaviest burden of malaria
the disease still kills around four
hundred thousand people a year
most are children under five and the
vast majority of all deaths occur
in africa where the disease continues to
perpetuate poverty
by one estimate malaria and tropical
diseases like it
knock a whole percentage point of
economic growth in sub-saharan africa
every year
but the death toll has fallen rapidly in
the past two decades
thanks to drugs and insecticide-coated
bed nets
and some african countries have done
especially well
senegal is one of the success stories
the rate of infection is only a fifth of
what it was 20 years ago
and below the average for sub-saharan
africa
the country hopes to be malaria free by
we need 2030 show that there is
possibility in africa to go
to zero cases part of the secret of
senegal's success
is cutting-edge genomics
scientists here study the parasites dna
to track how the disease is evolving
and identify mutations that might
indicate drug resistance
the role of the genomics is to support
for decision making
if a drug is not working sometimes it's
because
there are mutations in the specific
genes the genomics work
will help us to identify this
this helps policymakers keep one step
ahead of the parasites which has already
developed resistance to a host of drugs
the first effective cure for malaria was
found around
400 years ago in the bark of the
cinchona tree in the andes
jesuit priests brought it back to europe
but kept its origin
secret for years they carried favor with
the rich
and powerful by curing them of malaria
control of this wonder drug made the
catholic church
more influential fast forward to the
second world war
and sinchona bark had been refined into
queening
and the axis powers germany and japan
had seized most of the world's supply
which gave the japanese a big advantage
in tropical battles
when the americans surrendered on the
island of batan
85 of their army had malaria
of our 36 000 troops left in the last
days of bataan
20 000 were out on their feet or down
with malaria
this is your enemy remember her
the new york times said that they lost
not for want of ammunition
but for wanted malaria pills without
quinning
the allies were forced to rely on other
pills with nasty side effects
and an awareness campaign about the
dangers of being bitten
the female anopheles mosquito who hides
where she can't be seen
aided by pamphlets drawn by american
soldier
theodore geisel later known as dr zeus
some of them are very uh sassy if you
will using a
anne offali's mosquito as a you know a
seductress
sex worker if you will who preys on
unprotected gi's
so it was a a multi-front war against
malaria
walt disney used characters from this
playful classic to spread the message
dopey spray all the dark corners and
under thing
after the war governments tried to end
malaria by wiping out mosquitoes
they used a new pesticide that some
called the atomic bomb
of the insect world it saved millions of
human lives
it is a miraculous mosquito killer for
everything else it does
malaria rates during the 1950s are
reduced by 90
in numerous areas across the globe
but it also had side effects ddt lasted
a long time
and entered the food chain possibly
causing cancer
the overuse of ddt inspired rachel
carson to write
silent spring the book that kick-started
the modern green movement
in it she warned of the dangers of
slathering the planet with pesticides
without understanding their long-term
effects
widespread use of ddt was stopped in the
1970s
[Music]
today scientists are working on
different ways to control the disease
such as sequencing the genomes of the
parasite
in this lab in cambridge in england
scientists would normally be looking for
mutations in the parasites dna
but today they're using their experience
to sequence
covid19 it became clear
that the world was going to need
sequencing capacity to try to
answer some basic questions about the
virus where it was coming from
how it was spreading and ultimately
whether it was going to be sensitive to
vaccines
and so it was a no-brainer that we need
to contribute to that effort
they hope the increased public awareness
of disease control
brought about by the pandemic might also
help in the fight against malaria
congregate has alerted everyone to the
challenges
of tackling an epidemic and also to the
need for
accurate surveillance information that
is going to help i think
feed into the way we deal with other
diseases researchers recently estimated
that malaria could be eliminated within
a generation
if an additional 2.7 billion dollars a
year
was spent on prevention but with the
kovid 19 pandemic
far from over raising this extra cash
could be hard
so it's still too early to say how long
malaria will continue to shape the world
i'm robert guest i'm the foreign editor
of the economist if you want to read
some of our coverage of how malaria has
shaped human history
please click this link and please don't
forget to subscribe